get out the wheel Giancarlo Esposito as
Professor X he would do obviously a
great job at playing with genius like a
super genius that's also kind of
egotistical we are going people say rock
stars the x-men are celebrating their
20th anniversary on the big screen it's
the film that launched Kevin Feige as a
Marvel producer and now that his
precious mutants are back under that
sweaty ball cap fans are speculating
that everyone from G Carlo Esposito and
Logan co-star Daphne Keene could be part
of this MCU reboot but if not the x-men
where will they go this is rogue theory
the podcast said brings you the wildest
nerdy hot takes and a high-stakes
shootout I'm Erik Bosse and the
all-stars go and broke with me today
included our good buddy and resident
Gotham expert Tommy back tol hello I'm
back at my mom's house isn't that
exciting time truly is a flat circle you
just also with this college humor
comedian and writer Jessica Clemens
welcome back to the show hi this time I
changed out my family photo for a good
old fashioned Andy Warhol theme to cat
photos yeah it's it's all of our true
families right the cat no it's baby I
had to switch em out they weren't as
cool and someone added me at the
comments about it like I don't want to
bring my family and of course mastermind
of all things nerdy Joshua van Shire
Jobin welcome back to the show my friend
that's right joven Macho Man Shire here
taking you down
I'm the cream of the crop of going rogue
my friend oh yes Wow III feel a good
energy coming off you guys well that's
unfortunate because that's all I had
I've got big mom energy right now
what that means but I've got some big
mom energy I'm gonna bring orange slices
I'm gonna make sure everybody's blood
Sugar's up and if anyone needs to take a
break I've got a cold compress and
covered in a paper towel that you can
put on your head okay don't be late to
pick me up from soccer well let's dive
into it it's been a big week for the
x-men it's there's a fascinating article
about the original x-men film that
reassured us how Kevin Feige was
actually the voice of comics reason on
that set staying faithful to characters
backstories making sure Wolverines hair
shut it out from his head at just the
right angle I imagine him with a
protractor going up to new Jackman's
head but we also got some exciting news
this week from Giancarlo Esposito Gus
fring for Breaking Bad in bet across all
mouths Gideon from the Mandalorians Stan
Edgar from the boys sees the twos coming
up he straight have confirmed in an
interview that a Marvel role would
likely be his next step for his career
he's saying like he knows something he
knows something he said he's been
turning down smaller roles in Marvel TV
shows so that he could play a larger
role and a major title forget you
Jessica Jones season 3 I had asked for
title on my resume that I'm priming the
space for I would hear from you guys how
do you think Kevin Feige could use G
Carl Esposito to reboot the x-men or
some other upcoming MCU event Tommy why
don't I go first all right I got this
you know yeah I do think he definitely
was you getting approached to do a
Netflix show because I have a little
inside information that the leads of
those shows were all put under contract
it said that they could not play other
character would not play other Marvel
characters because they might be called
to play their characters and MC movies
if Marvel decided to do that so no Matt
Murdock
right there so well we had all the
information about a possible Punisher
reboot this week right so there is
chance that Jon Bernthal will play
Punisher Frank Castle again in some sort
of MCU property anyway so I look at the
quote in that article and Giancarlo
Esposito said that he wanted to play a
character that really did change the
world through their actions and I know a
lot of people have been speculating a
villain because
of what Giancarlo Esposito does he plays
bad guys so well but I think he might be
playing the maybe one of the greatest
heroes in the in the MCU Professor X
Charles Xavier I think that this will be
woven into the tapestry of the MCU as
we'll see him first arrive and I know I
sound like a broken record
in a post-credits scene in Doctor
Strange of the multiverse of madness I
really do think that this movie is going
to be kind of a doorway to many other
Marvel properties just it's built on the
kind of the axis of multiverses and
interdimensional goings-on I'll say so I
think that this really will open the
door for all these properties to be kind
of intertwined into the MCU without it
seeming to shoehorn did so how I think
it's gonna happen is is this Doctor
Strange in a post credit somewhere in
the in the actual movie he's going to
get it address and the address is a
mysterious location in Westchester and
it turns out to he gets there and it
looks like it's just this very expensive
private school for children and then
we'll get Benedict Cumberbatch saying
something snarky like well you guys seem
a little short maybe I'm a little too
tall to be here and just as he's about
to leave you'll hear Oh Steven you made
it then a beautiful British accent ish
type thing it out will wheel Giancarlo
Esposito as Professor X so what that's
going to see is where we go from there
and stop frustrates then says now I have
someone I want you to meet and we're not
going to see who that is that's going to
the screen is gonna go black but who he
is going to meet is magic magic from the
x-men who we know in some comic book
storylines does actually succeed Stephen
strange as the sorcerer supreme yeah so
I believe this is going to be a kind of
like almost a mentor-mentee yeah there
we go magic it's time Colossus has had
his day at the Sun it's time for a
little sis to get to get her moment so
yeah I don't think we we won't we
we won't get that yet but that's going
to ultimately be who they're going to
see so I know we wanted to set this up
as a movie so I will say this fall
Giancarlo Esposito is taking a break
from being bad this time Charles Xavier
is no chicken brother ah yes in a
three-minute post-credit scene after dr.
strange we have Giancarlo Esposito as
Professor X Aaron Paul as Warren
Worthington the 3rd aka angel and Elle
Fanning
as a placeholder for magic I could be
someone better than al Fanny but I just
watch the great and I feel like she
could pull it off well it's someone
someone stop me if I'm wrong here is it
are we gonna see magic in the New
Mutants isn't that one of the characters
and then in the New Mutants but it's the
new me is really gonna be tied into all
is it actually going to release yeah
it's in some way for sure it's gonna
happen so insert whatever actress is
playing Magic in the New Mutants in for
whatever I just said in in post John if
you're editing this just dub over my
mouth and say whatever that actress is
you can even do it a silly voice if you
want Tommy that is fascinating I love
the idea of a three-minute post-credits
scene I guess we have seen some
post-credits scenes just keep going on
and on and on Hobson Shaw had like 10
post-credit scenes and I'm like how is
that eager let's see what comes next
know what I do love about that is just
the idea of of Charles Xavier and
Stephen strange already being friends
you know as opposed to like these people
you know we're wondering where they are
like I think some people forget like
well if the x-men have been here the
whole time why haven't we seen them it's
just like well because the camera just
didn't pivot left 20 degrees like
they're there like they could've been
helping and all do battle they fight in
New York
we only saw like you know Upper
Manhattan yeah and I think that was my
favorite part of or one of my favorite
parts in Avengers endgame how we just
saw this the ancient one battling the
Chitauri it's like yes exactly
all the people just because they're
movies hadn't come out yet doesn't mean
these people weren't involved in these
fights so for sure
Charles Xavier could have been helping
out in all kinds of ways it's just the
camera hasn't shown that yet so that's
as simple as it needs to be this is
chicken cutlets Macedo rolls out at his
wheelchair
ah yes Steven my old friend remember how
in these past things how I did this and
I did that and actually a curb stomped
one of the Chitauri
and that's why I'm in this wheelchair
right now because these can't actually
handled that Chitauri skull intentional
strength that it's simple it's simpler
than even the wires making it right now
I'm making it too hard so who wants to
go next I can go next I will try and
follow that so I think that Esposito
will come back into the MCU plane as
Doctor Doom now hear me out I need dr.
doom to come back we need to see dr.
doom again I feel like every time you
see dr. doom we have such a different
origin story for whatever he's doing and
I I really love the lab experiment
blowing up but I also want to see and
maybe if we do get another and so I'm
trying not to spoil my own spoiler for
you guys I feel like if we get and what
I think we're gonna see them in is our
like our newest Avengers movie with the
newer Avengers so when Florence Pugh is
coming in when Anthony Mackie is playing
Captain America I think their villain
and that one is gonna be Doctor Doom
because he's like equivalent to Thanos
but he's a lot more aggressive I think
also we want to see black panther come
back so I feel like they'll tie that one
in will get spider-man coming back and
possibly possibly will get Monica from
the Captain Marvel series she's yeah so
I'm like cuz I've been rooting for her
to come in
I need young black girl superheroes
coming back in this world I need more
than Shuri like I think one of the
people in Black Panther so I was like
I've been counting down the time for
this so I feel like I would love him
playing Professor X obviously that is
amazing but I love Doctor Doom so much
he's such a good story that I don't want
him to just go under the rug I feel like
people are like yeah we see him a lot
but it's like we haven't seen him and I
feel like Esposito would do a good job
because he has that silky voice he's
very smart he's sexy just like dr. doom
I think you would do obviously a great
job of playing a genius like a super
genius that's also kind of egotistical
and just kind of cynical so I guess if
we're setting up the trailer for that
movie
January 10th my birthday 2026 2020 we
release this later this due to technical
difficulties but we where we open an
obviously an underground bunker lab they
love those scenes baby every other
scientist working on computers right and
I assume that's where all scientists
work now in bunker
damn straight hey they're working on the
computer and they they're like we're
getting a signal there's something
coming something large it's like who is
it is it a person isn't an animal and
they're like we don't know and then it
goes anthony mackie coming down and he's
like what's it up what was it chief to
Samuel Jackson of course and Samuel
Jackson's like something that we can't
figure out and it's coming very fast and
it's coming quick I'm talking like jaws
quick and it's dr. doom and he's like we
need to get everybody on this and he's
like I already did the elevator opens
and he's like is that Suri and she goes
nyet and it's flooring getting all the
Avengers back together and the end of
that movie is the Stinger of Deadpool
and the beach in Hawaii and he gets a
phone call and he goes I missed another
one yeah that's where I think he will be
I want to see him in the Avengers movies
I wanted to see him again I want to see
Doctor Doom
yeah oh Jessica I have to say like when
you're going through your trailer it did
have a bit of the Rickett 42 brother
it's like and and there's also grandmas
and they're gonna cross the tech and
sombrero it's just no I think she Carlos
Mencia would be great for Doctor Doom
because like yeah
he would bring so much immediate
gravitas to that role like people would
see his cast to be like yep yeah I'm
already afraid of this guy like what
kind of villainy he can bring to this
and I already kind of get where he's
coming from also like Zuko can play like
a Latvian like a made-up country like I
had to look this up I thought he was
like he had the same kind of Latino
roots that Gus fring has and he does it
he's natural and he's like yeah he's
like part Danish part Italian like so he
could just play anything anything and
then let be Rhea could be anywhere
sure yeah yeah so I love that idea
and I'm waiting to award points until
later I'm gonna make this a big reveal
at the end in case you're wondering
who's getting the roadies so joven tell
us what she got well well it's my turn
well you both bring up very interesting
points one giving him a protagonist role
and the other giving him in an anti and
antagonist role well he's uh he's gonna
show up and he's gonna show up a little
bit further down the road because you
know kovetz pushing everything back he's
not necessarily cast yet so this movie
is probably gonna wind up in phase 5 now
you guys end it with your little trailer
pitch I'm gonna start with mine just let
me paint you this scene blade is going
through the halls of a castle finally
caught up to the main villain of the
first blade movie Lilith that's right
got some great characters great casting
one of Blades strongest foes in fact but
of course blade wins that fight and as
he's about to win and and finish off
Lilith
she says you might have defeated me but
you've only angered my father and then
from the shadows comes out mr. Esposito
and he is her father
Dracula that's right he is going to be
like the Thanos of like the Marvel like
horror stuff that we're gonna be getting
on the side where Dracula's kind of in
charge of like all like the monsters and
bad guys of the demons and all that kind
of fun stuff because you
this guy's got gravitas he's got class
he's immortal just like his career so I
think having him play as as the big bad
over like a few different blade movies
maybe popping in some other stuff here
and there maybe some TV show appearance
also because there's what's happening
with the Avengers is great we're also
gonna be getting x-men and we're gonna
be Fantastic Four
we need some real draw and some real
attention on the other side of phase 5
so I'm thinking he's gonna be our
Dracula and now that we have a better
idea of his of his origin of his of
where he's actually from you know he's
got that that European aesthetic going
for him already so just go the distance
plus we really need a fixed Dracula from
blade Trinity so that that's the way to
go Wow that would be fascinated to see
like I can imagine those headlines right
like Gus fring now is Dracula and you
know like he's he knows like that
darkness so well and like he does come
from this like like horror inspired
place and yeah it's gonna be a very
difficult line I think for Marvel to
walk of embracing these like classic
horror supernatural things whenever they
do explore Ghost Rider and blade and
Mephisto and Lilith and all these other
things that they're clearly headed
toward and I feel like Giancarlo
Esposito can definitely do that me
because he's got that presence that just
kind of its eerie it's intimidating you
don't know what direction of bad things
are gonna go while he's standing in the
room for sure that's our Dracula alright
so for each of your theories I think
there's you did a great job introducing
who you want Jicarilla zero to play and
and what that trailer could look like
but now here's your chance to condense
it all into a tweet really just like no
use that word economy
you only have 240 characters this is
where you got to sell it with just a
tweet you're working for the Marvel
marketing department and here's a chance
to redeem anything that you felt unsure
about I I can trust all you guys need to
give you time to cope with some real
sexy upgrade for what your tweet some
real tweet redemption here and I can't
wait to hear your final bottom lines but
I'm gonna give you some time to do this
first I want to thank a sponsor of this
episode helix sleep so everyone the
world is insane right now we're all
under a lot of stress you're probably
not sleeping great I know I've been
having trouble some sleeping but this is
how helix has been helping me out helix
sleep makes these personalized
mattresses made right here in America
right to your door free no contact
delivery free returns a hundred night
sleep trial to choose a mattress Hilux
made a two-minute quiz that matches your
body type and sleep references to the
perfect matches for you
Hilux says the specific mattress for
each and everybody's unique tastes I
took the quiz and I was matched with a
helix mattress the helix luxe it's
perfect for this side sleeper who likes
a real cool feeling in bed I'm sleeping
so well it's like mantis has touched my
forehead each night that's like bathing
in my emotions and you know in NK I'm
sleeping on my side so in case you know
the overly sweet energy drinks have been
chugging all day come back up I'm not
gonna choke on him cuz I'm on my side
and my comforts mattress Hilux was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by GQ Wired
magazine and Apartment Therapy just go
to helix sleep calm slash rogue theory
take their two minutes sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free they leave it
big it up for you if you don't love it
but you'll love it helix is offering up
to $200 off all mattress orders in two
free pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep comm slash rogue theory that's
helix hg l IX sleep comm slash rogue
theory for up to $200 off also we want
to thank bespoke posts for sponsoring
this episode
most of the time the only thing in my
mailbox is notes where my neighbors
asked me to stop screaming or Mordor at
the top of my lungs sorry but once a
month
my box is a lot more exciting because of
my box of awesome from bespoke post
bespoke post sends guys only the best of
every month and no matter what you're
into box of awesome has you covered from
style and grooming goods to borrow we're
cooking tools and outdoor gear box
opossum has carefully built collections
for every part of your life I recently
got the Coos box which came with a great
summery linen shirt and the waterproof
beach wallet I haven't tested any of it
at the beach but the wallet is
definitely soda proof or overly sugary
energy drink proof because you know I
get my hand shake too much it smells
everywhere they also have multiple booze
themed boxes including the make
sparks that has fixins to make a Moscow
Mule spicy margarita yum yum yum to get
started take the quiz at box of awesome
calm to pick the right box of awesome
for you they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories it's free to sign up and you
could skip a month or cancel anytime
each box costs only 45 bucks but as over
$70 worth of gearing side get 20% off
your first monthly box when you sign up
at box of awesome comm and enter the
code rogue at checkout that's box of
awesome calm and code rogue for 20% off
your first box and we're back okay we
are gonna return to these theories and
I'm gonna award some points I got a
bronze and a silver and a gold it's
these are gonna be distributed based off
the quality of your tweets Redemption
who's going first oh sure alright so
mine is based on that popular tweet
format yeah sex is cool or yeah sex is
great so mine is yeah sex is cool but if
you tried gia Giancarlo Esposito in
charge of x-men school I love that you
worked in the format
well dice is next so it's in a very out
of the box type cast announcement we
actually have a tweet from Marvel that
says we're still trying to apologize for
blade Trinity and I think the only way
we can fix Dracula now is maybe with
this and then it's a it's a gif of Gus
walking out and Breaking Bad and fixing
his tie ah yes nice nice
and Jessica um do you want the silly one
or the sillier one what a great option
what a Sophie's Choice right now let's
go sillier Oh No okay let's assume that
you know Disney's super cool and really
care what goes on there Twitter it's the
same guy that runs the Wendy's Twitter
account he said or it says we've all
heard of Triple H but have you heard of
Triple D and there's his hashtag Doctor
Doom daddy
I'm John Esposito play with like the
mask off on dr. Doom's body of course I
also like the nod to blade Trinity with
Triple H they're very nice ok for this
round I will be awarding bronze to Tommy
bottom line Bechtold only because I know
we're gonna be to what we're talking
about next and that is your forte so I'm
gonna give you some room to grow or he's
over silver goes to JoVE and shire for
your theory I am Barry it just to see
general Isuzu does Dracula and gold goes
to Jessica Clemens because the trailer
cuz your two brothers style trailer so
great and getting in that Triple D in
there oh nice
so what song are we all gonna hum for
your national anthem on this Olympic
pedestal can we do like baby got back
does everybody know what a fun one to
hum
[Music]
that's good all right we're now gonna
move on to our discord rogue theory so
every week we play a game of rogue
theory with our patrons on new rock
stars official discord server this week
we had some patrons pitch theories about
how Yelena below this character will
continue to impact the MC after the
Black Widow movie and we had some really
really really good theories this week
including some strong ones from Gold
Komodo and Spanish 2002 but it was
Pharaoh Jeff that won the contest with
this theory that included some sick
references to the itsy-bitsy spider
comics working in some of that dialogue
because that was some great dialogue and
it ended with what I firmly hope is the
post-credits scene from one of these
movies Alayna beloved getting recruited
by Nick Fury director of sword yeah to
become a new Avenger well done
was it theory I just assume that's
what's actually happening right right
yeah that's got it this guy's got a look
at the script right or he rates or maybe
just Murrow Jeff is a is Kevin Feige
great kisser Jeff intense new director
wouldn't that be funny cuz that's where
he's get his theories from but some
weeks he doesn't win which is crazy I
mean I mean yeah yeah sometimes the the
fan theory is better than that just it
says keyboard yes Sinan you'll all see
you'll all see well you guys watching
can play to have your Theory read on an
episode of rogue theory in the future by
becoming a patron of new rock stars at
patreon.com slash new rock stars
all right onto our next topic last week
HBO max announced a new series about the
Gotham police departments set in the
same universe as the upcoming Matt
Reeves Robert Pattinson Batman film so
Jeffrey Wright is playing Commissioner
Gordon in that film it's looking like
he's gonna be the star of this series
and I'm guessing it's gonna feature less
of Robert Pattinson in every episode of
The Dark Knight
kind of similar to the Gotham series on
Fox that was Tommy's favorite show for
years yeah obsessed with it
well definitely not definitely not a
paid endorsement
well hey I mean I liked a lot of that
series but I'm very very excited for
this new HBO version of because I feel
like it can really go into some of the
like the grittier aspects of police
scene and lately folks writers all
across the TV and film industry are
refocusing how they depict police scene
on screen Brooklyn nine-nine s writing
staff throughout the scripts for their
first four episodes and they're starting
fresh it's a very interesting time this
is like a ripe opportunity for HBO to
depict new themes and police scene that
maybe evolved this show from the
standard you know Law & Order bad guy of
the week who procedurals were they just
kind of like move on to a new case and
they never show the lasting impact of
how the justice system affects these
people's lives they just kind of like go
they're thrown away in prison and we
never see what happens to those families
the victims or the perpetrators so I
think there's an exciting time to really
show the reality of police scene and I
feel like that that's gotta be what this
got them said she was gonna focus on in
addition to expanding the world of like
the bat waves Batman universe it's made
in the world of what it really means to
to be a cop and in the modern world so I
want to pitch I would hear pictures from
you guys how this Gotham Central show
could could expand the this new Batman
universe and tackle police and on TV in
a way that we haven't seen before I
could go first
only because I think I've watched the
least amount of God like I watched a
season and I got like two episodes into
the next one and I was like okay this is
exploding my head it's a ridiculous show
it's absolutely insane and it's so much
Rachel shoved in at once and I'm like
trying to keep track and I'm like oh my
god so I'm not talking crap though for
Fox no one please
get it but yeah so it seemed like and
feel free to correct me i feel like with
gotham fox that Fox's gotham that it
stopped becoming about the police
officers more than it became about the
details of a villains and then the
buildings had just such like kind of
archaic big like theatrical such weird
things going on that it was just like Oh
too much so I'm hoping that what I what
I personally want to see from the TV
show that's gonna go to HBO is they
to splice it together with how they're
handling Watchmen and how I want it to
be as real as possible but I also want
them to like expand the world of Gotham
I want them to I honestly kind of when
we bring in like static I would love to
see cyborg show also has such like a
dynamic background story it could
definitely be applied to Gotham itself
and then I think like Commissioner
Gordon will still be like the case I
think it'll be more of the fact of he's
kind of in the world where there's a lot
of a lot of corruption so he's just
gonna be like the one good light around
everything that's happening bad we might
see like a side of the Wayne family that
we don't want to see that makes them
look negative I think it's gonna be like
exploring so much more of that world but
I do want them to handle it how they do
Watchmen whereas like it's still that
move that show came out a while ago and
it's still very prominent especially
today where the racism and like police
brutality is a big deal and it's so hard
to like hopefully I want them to
approach it with like open arms and
obviously with a diverse writers room
because that's the thing that Brooklyn
nine-nine also has is that they have a
very diverse writing room a very diverse
head of cast and with a lot of DC shows
and a lot of Marvel things there's not a
lot of black people then Anthony Mackie
even brought that up recently how he was
like oh there's not a lot of brown and
white people on set or behind the scenes
or in front of the camera too so it's
like I want them to take it and like
they can do so well with it but they
need to open their doors in their mind
so what's happening in the world and
acknowledge it because even though
Gotham is not a really world it's still
a situation where we're like we don't
want to root for the bad guy oh you know
Jessica you bring up some really good
points especially about like revisiting
the Wayne family because you know
they've always been like heralded as
these patron saints of Gotham were cut
down too early but like I mean no one's
like that in real life like there are
good people who died but everyone's got
like you know a mixed bag in terms of
what they have been in their careers if
you have just seen to see if there's
skeletons in their closet doesn't mean
Batman himself has to be bad be
interesting to like revisit this
see if that factors into it alright who
is next next so yeah I have had the
pleasure of watching every episode of
Fox's Gotham and like and Jessica was
right on what happened to that shows it
became I mean literally they named one
of the seasons Gotham
I think : villains like it was finally
in the last season or two just kind of
gave up the gave up the brews that it
was gonna be about the GCPD and instead
it was like no we've created these are
just basically one-degree camera lens in
lighting darker character has done the
Adam West Batman they were fairly can't
be very larger-than-life this as was
perfect he was amazing
that guy but he but he went on to
greener pastures on Berry where he was
given more to do if that actor there
were several I mean even the guy who
played penguin was a huge Robin Lauren
Taylor huge like really really broad
performance but he was I mean he was
good there were moments of the show
where he was definitely carrying it but
they just never really fully developed
these characters in a way that you
really cared about them I think whereas
Gotham was a law-and-order type show
this new show is going to be a true
detective type show weaving in a couple
of different storylines all heading
towards one final like eat the seasons
gonna be about one thing ultimately
obviously Jeff writes character who I
don't think is the Commissioner again in
the movie he's he's just credited as Jim
Gordon right now and there's another
character on I am to be credited as
Commissioner I forget something
something so that is kind of usually how
this story is told right in Nolan's
Batman he was he was detective Gordon
first mankind McKenzie played detective
Gordon I don't think he became
commissioner till the last season so we
might still see Jim Gordon in some sort
of role there's also the Peter skarsgård
character that's a DA Gil Coulson which
is kind of funny that a character named
Coulson I wonder how that's because
that's such an iconic Marvel name now
Phil Coulson so whatever Coulson Coulson
but I wonder if that will be the kind of
law and order quote unquote where we
might see Peter scars guards character
carry on kind of the like you know the
litigious side of Gotham's prosecution
so I do think it
is an opportunity though to kind of
introduce these bad guys we've kind of
promised with Matt Reeves Batman that
it's gonna be a more cerebral approach
to Batman rather he's gonna be more of a
detective than a flashy like Joel
Schumacher throwing like back renée's of
people so I think this is an opportunity
to tell a slow kind of mystery and have
it be solved by Jim Gordon and and other
detectives that we might meet in the
movie and introduce them ultimately
probably leading towards a big bad bill
and I would say you know yeah I think
it'll be kind of a you know an
eight-episode march towards finding out
who who is behind a series of crimes in
Gotham City I'll law the way to
detective kind of takes 8 episodes to
unfold who is actually behind the
murders mysteries so that's what I got
ooh Tommy you know I loved true
detective well season 1 and season 3 I
could do without season 2 but it's
interesting how you say this HBO Gotham
is gonna be like true detective
Jessica was saying it's gonna be like
Watchmen because it's very true like
when these networks pitch these shows to
the to each other they're like what if
it's like Sopranos but this or what if
it's like Boardwalk Empire but this you
know they're all kind of doing versions
of things that they've done before so
yeah I'm kind of curious joven to see
what HBO series do you think it's gonna
be like uh so I'm making some
last-second changes to - I was just hit
with some inspiration and I like the
direction that you guys are going I
enjoyed the last half of Gotham and and
and to be completely honest I don't
think that there is a way to do it
without it just being Gotham again even
if you try to like make a strong stance
like no no it's gonna be about the the
PD well guess what after season one one
ratings aren't exactly where you want
them and you wanted to pop guess what
it's gonna introduce a bunch of villains
that you that we that we know before and
it's gonna then focus around them
because we like those characters more
than the other characters that's just
naturally where that show winds up going
because they're the more fascinating
characters to follow so I think that yes
they are going to do a Gotham PD style
show but it's not going to take place at
the same time with
saying universe yes time no now you're
also saying well joven it has to take
place during the same time because we've
got jeffrey wright coming back as Gordon
wrong Gordon my friend here's what we're
doing here's what we're looking at
here's what we're getting what is
another HBO property that was very prop
popular Deadwood
I think we're going back we're going
Wild West we are gone well people say
that's right we are going to get a Wild
West Gotham the the beginning of Goffman
we're gonna see Jeffrey Wright plane
Montgomery Gordon as he's sheriff of
these early early times of of Gotham and
you know let's get fun with it let's get
a little campy let's have like I don't
know some of these characters that might
mirror these villains but in the very
18th century kind of way I can see
there's a guy that comes to town that
sells ice like it's his job to sell ice
and he's also killing people with an ice
pick he's mr. freeze but now if they
really do want to focus on the cop side
of things they can also as an
alternative they can actually have this
take place during the gates of gotham
comic line that was written by kyle
higgins which guy it's it's like early
19th century i think i was very not
steampunky but a little Victorian ii
that you do see like the early
cobblepot's you see the early wanes kind
of like fighting over territory and
whatnot in and already built gotham so
there's two different places you can
take you take it early 1900s with
constable cops and whatnot or you know
we just go Wild West with the little
Deadwood meets Gotham
joven you truly went broke my friend
that way without that very interesting I
would love to see a period you just go
to Gotham story just to see the kind of
historical parallels see the origins of
Gotham so yes it works now I'm gonna
give everyone a chance to you know
condense their theories into tweets form
here's your chance to get some true
tweet Redemption working out all the
kinks pitch it back to me that's I'm
gonna award those points but while
they're doing that I want to thank our
friends at manscaped for sponsoring this
episode
manscaped offers precision-engineered
tools forget family jewels
they spent eighteen months designing a
lawn mower 3.0 it is the greatest
freakin
body hair trimmer the world has ever
seen it is a waterproof it has a 90
minute battery so you get a full hour
and a freaking half to clear all that
real estate you got down there it's got
an LED light you know so you can do it
at nighttime anytime at night I don't
care I'll be doing this all night
grunting and how much fur I got a trim
waking up all the neighbors manscaping
accidents are a thing of the past thanks
to man escapes skin safe technology in
the case you don't want to wake up the
neighbors they got a quiet stroke
technology on their 7000 rpm trimmer
motor and by the way this whole thing
vibrates so if you want to put this in
anywhere go for it get 20% off and free
shipping with the code rogue theory at
manscape comm that's 20% off and free
shipping at manscape calm and use the
promo code rogue theory so let's return
to our Gotham PD theories give them back
to me in a tweet here's your chance to
really sell me with that bottom line
goes the exclamation point hashtag
Instagram on Fox get ready for the new
hit on HBO max this is why I need to
write down my tweets okay so mine is a
photo it's a video of the true detective
season 1 DVD boxset and then slowly a
knife lowers down on it cutting it in
half revealing that it is cake and then
you pull the DVD in half and inside it's
a bat it's a Batman themed cake and you
see that holding the knife is Geoffrey
right awesome I've got just a one tweet
by HBO max and it's a hashtag goth wood
very confusing hashtag but it is a video
of like a point of view of someone like
pushing in some swinging door
sattell I got a saloon and then someone
goes Gordon that you and then just you
know Jeffrey right turns around and tips
his cowboy hat and then cut the black
mmm you know God wood is what I got is a
teenager whenever Evanescence came on
the ring wake me up down there yes I
loved all three of your theories equally
because I would love to see any version
of these shows they all have their
strengths that make them all valid and
wonderful but based on your tweets alone
Jessica I'm afraid I'm gonna have to
give you bronze just you just weren't
prepared on that one but it's okay still
get a bronze why no job is my friend me
I'm giving you the silver because goth
wood as a term just might be a bit
confusing copy that to people you know
Tommy you take the cake with the gold
well done how come the fat guy gets gold
for a cake joke okay we are now gonna
move on to rogue questions are you guys
ready doesn't matter cuz here it come
okay
because only drive-in theaters are open
right now the Empire Strikes Back was
the number one movie at the box office
last weekend what's the best possible
drive-in movie and why a lot of driving
theaters are kind of reliving these
glory days of like old 80's movies and
that's not bad but I think there's I
think we can create a new generation of
drive-in movies with today's classics
and I'm going with Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world didn't do as well it should have
as it should have the first time around
in theaters it deserves a second chance
go watch it in a drive-in Edgar Wright
giving some gold with that movie yes I'm
gonna go with the movie that I actually
saw for the first time at a drive-in
features a scene at a drive-in and is
just all around a classic pee-wee's big
adventure it's got it all
it's got scares with large barge it's
got an action Francis is kind of a
monster so there's a little bit of a cut
so uh hang in there
pee-wee's big adventure nice I'm a big
horror person always been a big [ __ ]
fan and also like a lot of people big
80s horror fan and I go to the drive-ins
weekly because I have nothing to do and
I'm going on Thursday just so you guys
know I'm seeing Enter the Dragon and Big
Trouble in Little China
wow I'm so excited but I think for a
drive and I would love to live that
nostalgia days that my mom did as a teen
and go see Nightmare on Elm Street put
me in a war situation all right next
question James Gunn said in a tweet this
week that he could see sue
scooby-doo's mystery gang and the
Suicide Squad being in the same movie
what is the best mystery for those two
groups to solve together I don't have a
mystery for them to solve I just want to
make sure they all play by the same
rules and that is death dollars if they
get out of line because as a kid it used
to really stress me out
when shaggy would not follow the rules
and would stray off into different rooms
that was a rule abiding kid so now if
shaggy goes off until I got a haunted
painting room his head just explodes at
first I wanted them to solve like the
Zodiac killer stick with that because I
was like if you put Scooby Doo's the
mystery gang into the like the Suicide
Squad world it's gonna be some crazy
[ __ ] and I want to see a real murder I
think what we're gonna have here is
shaggy actually gets arrested for
possession of marijuana gets gets pulled
in by Waller and says you're gonna be
working on a new mystery with this group
of people over here we need to find out
who is Batman and then and then Shaggy's
like why would I work for you and then
while it's like well we can get you to
work and it's not a collar it's actually
he looks down the hallway and and
someone's walking up Scooby Doo and he's
like yo raggy
[Laughter]
all right and then lastly Ludacris let
it slip in an interview that Fast and
Furious 9
we'll be going to outer space oh he said
in your best terrible Vin Diesel voice
what will Dom Toretto say in space I I
imagine I imagine so everyone's waiting
for them to take off right everyone's at
the ground there watching them take off
all of them all of them in a rocket ship
looking like a car they fly into the
immediately goes off everyone's like
there they go there they go and there
goes I've been diesel and he goes
starlight Starbright
[Laughter]
it's it's him he's it he's in his
spaceship he's got three other people
with them in their own spaceships and
he's just like down five checking in
yeah I think it's gonna be Dom Toretto
staring wistfully out the window of a
Camaro that's been modified to fly in
space and he's gonna say Mars ain't the
type of place to raise a kid cold as
hell and there's no one to raise them if
you did I don't understand it's just a
job five days a week a rocket man I love
it
Tommy you're gonna get the win for that
one buddy ah and that makes you the
winner of this episode oh my god I feel
very blessed to have one that does I
feel like at the Aetherius were fine but
I feel like we're actually theories
there so I so I also win good I would
have definitely won had I just said I am
Groot that's all he needs to say in that
movie failed this podcast all right so
but Tommy you get your wish what would
you like to see in the world my wish is
just gonna be a little extra work for
our editor job we all need to freeze
frame and then John needs to write what
happened to us all five years later like
so everybody hold in place and whatever
pose they wanted that job go ahead and
say what happened to each one of us
you know we don't need to hold that we
have to hold it yes I know that was my
real wish I tricked you well that is it
for this episode of rogue theory a big
thanks to our guests who got some great
ideas in here lots of laughs Tommy
Bechtold thank you
Jessica Clemens and her cat and Joshua
overtired joven I'm going home and I'm
going rogue don't forget to subscribe to
the rogue theory podcast feed stay tuned
for the YouTube channel for this and
other shows follow us on Twitter at new
rock stars see you guys next week
[Music]